hey everybody thank you so much for
checking out our post III video my name
is Mike Laidlaw I'm the creative
director for Dragon Age Inquisition and
today we're going to show you how our
mix of exploration real-time and
tactical combat and Bioware's
award-winning storytelling are going to
come together into one unforgettable
experience while we showcased any number
of combinations at e3 for this demo we
want to go with the fan favorite and
play the female
qunari mage Inquisition is the biggest
Dragon Age game in fact this area that
you'll see here and you can go virtually
anywhere that you can see in the
landscape is larger than the entire play
space of Dragon Age Origins and it's not
the only one Inquisition is built of a
series of multiple regions allowing you
to travel from blistering deserts to
demon infested swamps over the course of
your adventures
Templar bastards killed my husband and
stole the ring from his finger they
deserve to die you're saying the
Templars attacked your husband aye he
was digging out a stump
the fools couldn't tell a shovel from a
major staff had to be safe they said
rebels everywhere attacking by surprise
sick bastards they took the ring I gave
him on our wedding day in case it was
magic fell well this location as you've
just heard is struggling as the mages
and Templars are vying for control and
every location you visit is part of the
larger story and is a space you can
impact with your actions rather than
just tell you that the mage and Templar
conflict is a threat we wanted to make
sure that you were a part of it
with Inquisition we want to go beyond
random encounters and instead we built
the world master system one that ensures
that nara's population is directly
influenced by you and how you choose to
play hunt all the bears in a region for
their hide
perhaps for a new suit of armor and
their numbers will dwindle
similarly spread your Inquisition to a
region and you will see your troops
patrolling the roads and signs of their
presence Inquisition is one of the most
dynamic RPGs you will ever play view of
the Kings Road from up here
our goal today is to bring the war
between the mages and the Templars to an
end and our first step on that journey
is to reach the village of Red Cliff as
you saw from the encounters happening
below where mages and Templars are
actively fighting in order to reach that
location we're going to have to get our
hands dirty
now Dragon Age always puts you in the
role of a leader and at all times you're
in a command of a team that you've
assembled and outfitted yourself the
enemies you encounter in the world are
also working as a team using their
abilities and environment in intelligent
ways to pose challenges up here you'll
see a simple example as the mages throw
down glyphs to deny us areas forcing us
to attack from different directions
looks like the mages are enjoying
themselves
come on we're not gonna solve this by
sticking around here
combat an inquisition pits your
abilities against your foes and so we
can take a closer look at what's
happening here using our tactical view
the Templar defender has a massive tower
shield preventing us from attacking the
front and you'll notice that our
characters respond to how the battle is
playing out arrange character staying at
the back and at any time we can switch
to any member of our party to take
direct control
here you can see why we want to bring
this conflict to an end the battles
between the groups are tearing this area
apart in Inquisition you must be the
leader of leaders iron bull who we see
when our party is a commander of his own
mercenary company Viviane was the first
enchanter of the Circle of Magi and
every member of your party shares this
kind of influence and expertise
Inquisition also includes our largest
cast of characters to date including
returning favorites from previous Dragon
Age titles all of them have come
together to join our cause the
Inquisition
throughout the game you'll be spreading
your influence across the world setting
up new camps deploying troops and
fortifying strongholds and as we make
our way onto one now you'll see that to
travel these massive spaces Inquisition
is introduced mounts for the first time
in the Dragon Age game in addition to
the Ferelden Bey we have here there are
numerous exotic mounts also available
for you to acquire collect and ride
across the land
Inquisitor we're honored
I heard rumors that there are reports
tonight outside the city right in the
temple I think we should go go in the
middle of the wall
in Inquisition your party members have
their own goals aspirations and they
will often pause while exploring to
share them with you or with each other
the next time we think of the mayhem
Sara look you and Varick are the only
ones small enough and will do some
bloody presses redcliffe is serving as a
staging ground for my forces with the
mage and templar war spiraling out of
control we've realized that to bring it
to an end we need to infiltrate here Red
Cliff castle a mage stronghold
exploration zones such as this one are
filled with opportunities to grow the
influence and power of the inquisition
will travel to a previously explored
camp to pursue one of those now of
course we know there's a sincere threat
ahead so it's a chance for us to nerd
out a bit as we dig into the inventory
and look at the weapons and armor of our
party here we'll switch down with the
iron bull and grab that battle master
mail we looted earlier while we were
exploring this changes his appearance
and of course if you don't want to use
just looted armor you do have extensive
crafting materials to choose from
in Inquisition every character fulfills
a unique role as you build your unique
strategy you'll have over 200 abilities
spells and upgrades to choose from in
order to give every character in your
party their own unique role and style of
fighting
while the little ones go down easily
enough the high dragon is the apex
predator of the Dragon Age World
Inquisition dragons are so large that
we've changed the way you target them
individually attacking their limbs and
their tails in order to bring them down
if you can inflict enough damage you'll
be able to change the flow of the fight
rather than mana or stamina a spell like
haste uses focus a resource built up
only through teamwork focus abilities
are incredibly powerful allowing us to
wound this dragon's leg and bring it
down but in order to use them you have
to build them up overtime making them
very strategic in how you deploy them
into each fight
alive
Inquisition is the biggest Dragon Age
game we've created and it represents the
next generation of Bioware RPGs with a
massive world dynamically reactively
populated based on your decisions a
massive cast of legends and an
inquisition feud a lead in a variety of
tools with which to destroy your foes
including tactical and real-time combat
this is the Dragon Age game we've always
wanted to make thank you so much for
checking it out